video
finally before starting with your
questions let me remind you that we will
finish this midday briefing at the
latest at 1 pm in order to
give place to executive vice president
valli zombrowskis commissioner paolo
gentiloni and commissioner nicolas
schmidt
they will present to you the autumn
semester package which was discussed in
college yesterday and on which you've
already had a technical presentation
just before
this midday
later at 2pm we
are organizing an on the record
technical briefing
on the ecdc's assessment of the current
kovid 19
situation
we will have the director of the ecdc
andrea ammann as well as marco cavaleri
head of the biological threats and
vaccines strategy
of the european medicines
agencies you will be able to follow this
briefing
live on ebs
that is all for our announcements today
we can start with your
questions
i will start with a question yes from
the press room
please
hold on it was cut off go ahead yeah
thanks eric cartesian katrina from the
czech press
um i asked you eric last week about the
decision of austrian government
not to peep not to consider people
vaccinated with janssen vaccine as being
vaccinated starting in january of next
year that's the decision of the austrian
government when i asked you last week
you told me you were not aware of that
decision of austrian government now it's
five day plus so i'm sure that you are
aware of that so i have a question since
there are also some czech slovak uh
hungarian citizens who have already
contacted your um direct center europa
direct center with their questions on it
so the question is
how can you
assure a fair treatment of eu citizens
if one government decides
one day from the other not to consider
people vaccinated with one of the
vaccines accredited by emma
as being vaccinated
indeed the government is
going to see those people as
non-vaccinated started next year january
and so to say will require personal
lockdown of these people and sure i'm i
you can imagine that there are people
who are owning properties in austria
from neighborhood countries so for them
if they are vaccinated with the enzyme
it's
it means a major obstacle to their daily
life thanks
thank you um
so this is actually a question
not so much about whether janssen as a
vaccine is recognized or not it's a
question about the validity of the
recognition right
which
which is the length of validity sorry
the length of the validity of the of the
recognition which is a question which i
think we have seen popping up
um across various member states with
statements uh being made uh by um
by various authorities in in member
states and as i think christian has been
saying
um consistently on the podium these last
couple of days
the commission is working
on um is reviewing its recommendation
when it comes to free movement within
the eu
so i would ask you to wait until we come
forward with
our
revised recommendation on this
to get an answer to your question
any other questions
on
the eu digital kovid certificate bearing
in mind
what i've just said on
on the fact that
we will be coming forward at a later
point in time with a
modified recommendation
vince i see you have your
hand raised in the interaxial
app
is it on this
vince you have to change your mic source
there you go it's working go
hi you can hear me yes
yes
thanks um no it's not about this so if
you'd like to stay on kovit i can come
back
hey
please unraise your hand if you are not
your questions do not concern the
subject
that we are discussing i may come back
to you very quickly but let me just
check first if there are other questions
on this
it is not the case so in the events we
can't come back to you go ahead
go ahead you got me yeah go ahead yeah
yeah sorry
so thank you um
so i again asking about something i
asked about yesterday um
which i was dealing with tim on
around the ebrd and a loan to egypt
which is now not going ahead this was a
250 million dollar loan for an aura
refinery
um and i've been asking the commission
for a week whether you support this loan
or not
i've been hearing that
that you didn't and you're kind of
lobbying against it
now the loan's not going ahead
but i'd still like to know whether the
commission is happy sad or indifferent
about that news thanks
tim
hi vince sorry to disappoint you but we
are not going to express happiness
sadness or indifference about a project
which has been
withdrawn
which is which is not on the table
anymore i mean we told you where we
stood
um the other day very generally and you
were asking about this in the context of
the european green deal i think there
were some further exchanges with
colleagues but this is a project which
is no longer on the table
for us that's where the issue lies
vince you have a follow-up
yes thanks
um
it it's not the case that you told me
where you stood you told me for a week
you were going to tell me where you
stand and then the project collapsed and
now you're saying oh we can't tell you
because it's not happening so
at no point in that process did you have
to say what you think and that's what
i'm asking
vince again i mean there's
however many of these projects that come
through various processes that get to
different points in the decision-making
stage the commission does not publicly
express where it stands step by step in
each decisions um doesn't necessarily
depends on the process this one is not
in my direct responsibility but confirm
publicly votes and necessarily even have
a voting role in these kind of decisions
so there's really i'm sorry to
disappoint you but nothing i can tell
you about
anything more about this project
thank you are there other questions on
energy topics for tim
that is not
the case
so i go back to marina
thank you tim
tristano and it's regarding belgrade
priest in the dialogue
um
if peter is there um no peter so um
yesterday uh we had the situation
where uh the chief negotiator of
belgrade was denied entry in kosovo and
metochia
and since you and eu representatives
already called
um
priesthood aside to respect the the the
agreements reached so far but they are
doing this thing again and again is
there something that you or eu can say
or do for this thing not to happen again
this is the first question the second
question is that after the yesterday's
talks um between mr leichchuk and the
president of serbia alexander woodrich
alexander what said that belgrade is
ready as soon as possible to talk with
pristina and do you maybe know what is
the position of priesthood regarding
this
does will mr elijah go to pristina and
talk about this with
with them with albin kurti and regarding
albin courty also he said again that his
vision of kosovo is
uniting with albania so far
uh this
when we are looking at the dialogue uh
this is undermining the the core of the
dialogue that eu is leading here so is
there something that you can say
regarding this thank you
thank you marina uh three things on the
first one regarding the visit i think
most recently it was last monday when
the ministers of uh 27 eu member states
have met and they uh among other things
were discussing also the situation in
the western balkans and they were
mentioning also the dialogue and they
stated very clearly that they expect
kosovo and serbia to fully respect and
implement
all the previous agreements reached and
constructively engaged
in the eu facilitated dialogue on the
progress of this of this comprehensive
normalization of relations these
expectations expectation is still there
this call
by 27 eu member states is there for
constructive engagement and for
respecting and implementing all the
agreements that have been reached
on the fact that mr petkovic was
denied visiting kosovo i can only say
that the call and expectation about
respecting and implementing all past
agreements includes also the agreement
on official visits these visits official
visits between both sides are important
contribution and important part of the
normalization of the relations
and
asparagus agreement all visits need to
be conducted in a way that advances the
dialogue and advances the normalization
of the relations and contributes to the
progress within the dialogue so uh
we are we we know as far as we know the
visit of mr petkovic was appropriately
notified in line with the agreement and
therefore it should have been allowed to
take place and we call on kosovo to
reconsider the decision and allow this
visit to proceed
on the second question um you special
representative miroslav
in the follow-up to this discussion uh
by the foreign ministers went uh to
belgrade and he already met uh prime
minister kurt in vienna earlier this
week then he went to belgrade to talk to
president
to deliver and reinforce the message and
the expectation of the eu 27 member
states that we want to see progress
and he will also continue to pristina
tomorrow to have more talks on the issue
in order to press this message home and
advance the work on preparing next
high-level meeting that we hope will
still take place
this year
and
remind me the third question
please
albin courtney saying again that he sees
possible in uniting with albania
right
generally we don't comment on remarks by
others i understand he was commenting in
a hypothetical context so this is a
reason even more for us not to comment
on hypothetical scenarios and remarks
about hypothetical things but uh here
the line of the eu the expectation of 27
member states of the european union is
very clear we expect the leaders in
western balkans to lead by example when
it comes to constructive engagement and
responsible behavior and responsible
statements that go into the direction of
enhancing the reconciliation regional
cooperation and good neighborly
relations and not to the contrary so
this is all i can say about is that this
position of the eu is very well known
and is being stressed very very uh it is
being searched repeatedly that we expect
the leaders to behave act and pronounce
themselves
responsibly in line with the european
aspirations of their people
thank you marina you have a follow-up
thank you eric just this short one did
you
send this message directly to mr corti
when you say we said to all of the
leaders
but did he receive this message directly
from you
i think all the positions and all the
messages of the european union are very
clear to our partners and if they are
not we continue delivering them to the
partners uh repeatedly at the different
levels at different occasions now the eu
special representative in the aftermath
of the dedicated discussion by the eu
foreign ministers about western balkans
and also about the dialogue went to meet
prime minister kurti and went to meet uh
president vutic so of course in the
aftermath of the fac he was delivering
the latest and most recent clear
messages and expectations uh by the
european union from both leaders and
from both sides
okay thank you very much i will close
this chapter because we're slightly
short on time today in case there are
many other topics that would come up but
are there other foreign affairs
questions
for peter today please let me keep your
hand raised if your question is on
foreign affairs khalid
how do you have a question go
would like to have a response of
european union regarding the
distinguished human rights defenders
arrest and he was taken
to far away jail in jammu and kashmir mr
khuram purveys he has been award award
he has been awarded
many european human rights awards and
he uh he's contributed
to united nation report and united
nation already
uh demanded his immediate unabated
release what is the response of uh
europe union regarding this arrest
thank you this is a question for nabila
thanks a lot
khalid for your questions uh for your
question we have received reports on the
arrest of the human rights activist
juram pervez
and seen the worrying comments by
mary lawyer
loy lor the un special reporter on human
rights defenders we follow
developments in jammu and and
kashmir closely it is essential
that individual rights are fully
respected the eu's consistent position
worldwide is that all allegations of
human rights violations be investigated
in line with international human rights
commitments wherever they are committed
freedom of expression online and offline
is a key value for all democracies and
as you know we hold regular
consultations on these issues with our
indian counterparts including through
the eu india human rights dialogue which
was resumed in april
thank
you are there other questions on foreign
affairs for us today
that is not the case thank you nebila
are there other issues for us today
yes go ahead
oh this is on uh migration follow-up on
uh commissioners hinasa's
announcements yesterday
it's two specific things on this on the
measures on belarus first of all when he
when we when the commission mentions uh
the examination of provisional measures
based on article 78.3 what exactly that
entails what that includes uh when it
comes to that and secondly could we have
a little bit more on this uh
proposal to typify
instrumentalization of migrants under
schengen
me point out obviously on the proposal
on 78.3 that
you know we will provide you with all
the details when the proposal comes out
where the commission is currently
working on it
that's uh
that's indeed exactly correct um i would
perhaps
simply at this point uh be able to refer
you to what the president said yesterday
in the parliament plenary um and uh what
was then further expressed in the in the
press conference by vice president xinas
and in response to the questions uh it
it is uh about helping member states uh
respond effectively to the hybrid threat
uh that um
that they are facing uh it will be um
it will be in the spirit of the crisis
proposal that is included in the new
pact on migration and asylum uh and it
will complement the support to the
organizational humanitarian
organizations working on the ground the
outreach to the countries of origin and
transit to stop people from coming to
belarus and of course the proposal made
yesterday to sanction transport
organizations involved in the smuggling
or trafficking of people
and
when it comes to the the issue of
instrumentalization of migrants
i will have to give you a very similar
answer it's something that we are
working on very intensively right now uh
with the view to presenting the um the
the proposals on the schengen borders
code which will of course also address
all the other aspects of um of the
schengen reform
and it is in the listed point preview
currently for
the 8th of december however as eric
constantly emphasizes right and very
much rightly so it's only an indicative
document thank you very much adelbert
other questions
on
home affairs for adelbert today
i see
no further question for you at albert so
i go back to peter who has
raised his hand
in on the interaction platform peter you
have a floor
you need to press speak
thank you very much
i have two questions relating to the
blacklisting that was put out yesterday
one is uh simply on account on uh
this
uh
phrasing of a new legal framework to uh
to target measured against transport
operators operators engaging in or
facilitating smuggling or trafficking
does that include the unknown transport
of people if you sell for instance a
train ticket to someone without knowing
that it's actually human trafficking or
not detecting a stowaway
stephen
uh peter thank good afternoon thank you
very much for asking this question
well you know yesterday we have set
indeed the legal framework and the
objective of this legal framework is to
identify a couple of measures which are
not acceptable which are irregular
activities which help committing
trafficking and smuggling of people and
which therefore have to be
um
followed by sanctions and the list of
sanctions is identified here
the regulation clearly identifies the
number of situations
which are considered to be irregular
situations such as indeed as you said
use transport means the commission of
smuggling
of migrants or trafficking pers in
persons i'm not in a position to this
will obviously require a very solid
assessment of the situation um whenever
measures are taken we'll have to analyze
very thoroughly the context the the the
facts that are throwing the case and on
that basis if it turns out that what
happened has indeed led to this
commission of smuggling of migrants then
measures can be taken but i'm not in a
position to discuss all possible uh
facts or which would or would not be
covered by this um
by this definition it has to be looked
at
on the base of the context and the facts
and i think rationale the objective is
quite clear those transport operations
that participate in such actions
can indeed be sanctioned or should be
blacklisted thank you
and if i may add a word there will
always be the opportunity for the
transfer operator to comment on the
findings of the commission
peter you have a follow-up
thank you um it's uh
so so as i as i hear it it's on a
case-by-case basis uh so so essentially
it's sort of hard to tell right now
which ones would constitute one or the
other um when you look at the q a
there's also a part that says that is
the the transport means in the
commission of smuggling migrants uh has
the commission factor into that whether
that will also include for instance car
rentals or ship brokers
people who are not uh who don't drive
the bus so to speak but may rent out a
bus
um thank you very much peter to start
with i would like to stress that
transport operators are transport
operators covered by or
active in the different transport modes
so air maritime train road transport all
modes are covered here and again on the
base of the facts we will have to see
to what extent such transport operators
are covered by this commission of
smuggling of migrants or trafficking
persons again taking into account the
context the facts because this requires
a very solid assessment of course
followed as eric said by the possibility
for the transport operator to
to be heard thank you
thank you
are there other questions on transport
issues for stefan
no
any other questions for us today
it seems not so thank you very much and
stay tuned now at one for the press
conference on the european semester
you